hey youtubers is Charlie welcome to
another edition of anime club this time
it's going to be all about attack on
Titan hopefully you've all had a chance
to see it since it's been on crunchyroll
for a while and it's on Netflix now I
know a bunch of you read the manga too
before we get started quick shout out to
the winners from my last anime club
Chloe right you win a $20 Amazon gift
card and itsy-bitsy Irish girl you get
to pick a future anime club topic I'll
be messaging both you guys on your
channels for details
if you're finding me for the first time
in each of my anime club videos I pick
random subscribers from the comments to
get free stuff too so first let's talk
about our top 5 WTF moments from season
1 of the anime then I'll talk about the
live-action film and then season 2 the
anime careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen season one yet but everyone
bite your thumbs and let's get going for
anyone that's curious I'll be drinking
brainless IPA during this hopefully I
won't be brainless by the end number 5
the first appearance of the Colossus
Titan in episode 1 the promotional
material had already spoiled the Titans
for non-readers but just like Game of
Thrones red wedding all of that did
nothing to dull the shock of seeing that
giant Titan appear at the wall for the
first time the other Titan shifters
would gradually appear over the series
and they were definitely WTF moments but
after we got used to the shock of the
skinless steaming pile of scary the
biggest thrill morphed into the
mysteries of their identities isn't it
funny that the Colossus Titan was one of
the first ones that we saw but we didn't
learn its identity till after we learned
the identities of all the other Titan
shifters number 4 the female Titan
reveal I didn't read the manga before
seeing her for the first time in episode
17 there were so many red flags about
that Titan mostly the fact that she
looked like she was designed to fight in
close combat giant WTF I really loved
the flashbacks we got AB & E being
trained by her father in episode 23 so
much of the series of this really dark
psychological drama but unless you've
read ahead in the manga she's still
stuck in that crystal cocoon the biggest
question I had after learning the
identities of the human Titans at least
the sinister ones was a giant why you
know why are you doing this I guess you
could call that a rage why number 3
Aaron gets nom by a Titan worst
cliffhanger in the history of
cliffhangers it was such a huge moment I
screamed in my chair for a week until we
found out what happened this actually
brings up a minor complaint of the
series and that the intros and the
outros make it feel like each episode
has varied
new content like almost half the episode
is spent talking about previous episodes
and the next one so this really became a
meta WTF moment because of what happened
to Aaron and then later because of that
giant middle finger they gave us with
the cliffhanger number 2 Aaron was
revealed as a Titan shifter he was the
protagonist of the series so he had to
come back somehow
before that epic shifter reveal I
actually thought that he would cut his
way out from the inside the series
doesn't really do a good job of
explaining the Titans digestive systems
but in my head I kind of thought that
they were like mini Sarlacc pits where
people would usually just die from the
impact of falling down their throats or
they'd die from starvation if the Titans
didn't vomit them back up quick sidenote
someone should totally try and start an
extra-credit course at school for Titan
biology I could do an entire video for
Aaron but he's not my favorite character
mostly just because he seems so
reluctant to embrace his new abilities
he spends the rest of the season up to
his fight with the female Titan just
trying to decide how he feels about
being a Titan which is why he's such a
terrible fighter whenever it comes time
to lay the smackdown on Annie something
every anime science fiction and fantasy
series needs is a montage where the hero
tests their abilities and learns how to
control them
I feel like Aaron waited a little too
long to do that it's like his montage
happened while he was getting his ass
kicked by Annie I was actually surprised
that he was able to defeat her but he
did have the help of the survey corpse
and Mikasa and my number one WTF moment
no surprise here Titan in the wall this
raised so many questions like are all
the walls made of Titans is the city
just wall-to-wall Titans who put them
there and most importantly why are they
there it seems like someone has a grand
plan for all these people they're not
the only city in existence so we still
need to learn if all these shifters came
from another group trying to subjugate
the city so many questions for season 2
so let me know what was your biggest WTF
moment from season 1 and what is your
biggest question that you want to see
answered in season 2 we should all
probably pour one out for all of our
fallen comrades - now here's a quick
update on that live action film right
now they're getting ready to start
filming this summer with an expected
release date of summer 2015 if you saw
the Subaru commercial with the CG Titans
the movie's director worked on it but
they don't know if the Titans in the
movie will look like those Titans no
cast has been announced but since we are
getting close to their film date we
should find out who they are pretty soon
also here's a quick update on series 2
of the anime the studio that produced
series one studio wit isn't going to
start working on season 2 till either
late this year or next year meaning that
it's going to be awhile before we see it
they said that this year they're
actually producing a different anime
series called Hazuki retsu so if you
like the animation on titan you should
definitely check that out
so I'm not going to wait a full week to
post my next anime club video I want to
do a review of Miyazaki's the wind rises
and it's opening wide in theaters now so
you should all be able to find somewhere
to see it remember I'll be picking two
subscribers from the comments as my next
giveaway winners I'll announce who that
is in the review video I'll try and post
that tomorrow morning right now click
here for my top 5 evil anime characters
and click here for my top 5 Miyazaki
films thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tomorrow
high fives